CAROLINA TOMORROW, GUYS.
>> Todd: LAUREN, THANK YOU,
LET'S BRING IN JANICE DEAN,
OBVIOUSLY A TOUGH DAY YESTERDAY,
WHERE ARE WE GOING FORWARD?
>> Janice: AREA OF LOW PRESSURE
IS OVER ORLANDO, THEY WILL SEE
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WIND AND
RAIN, THIS IS LANDFALL, 12 HOURS
AGO.
WE HAD LANDFALL NEAR CAYO COSTA,
THAT IS WHERE HURRICANE CHARLEY
MADE LANDFALL, ALMOST THE EXACT
SAME SPOT, THIS STORM WAS THREE
TIMES THE SIZE OF CHARLEY AND
TOP FIVE MOST POWERFUL
HURRICANES THAT HAS EVER HIT THE
U.S.  HERE IS WATER RISE IN FORT
MYERS, THIS IS BEFORE WE STOPPED
GETTING UPDATES.
WE'LL SEE HIGHER TOTALS, BUT TO
PUT IN PERSPECTIVE, THIS WOULD
BE HIGHEST STORM SURGE FORT
MYERS EVER FELT IN THEIR
HISTORY.
TOP WIND REPORT, 140 MILE PER
HOUR AT CAPE CORAL, PUNTA GORDA,
ONE SPOT WHERE CHARLEY MADE
INCREDIBLE DAMAGE IN 2004.
TOP RAINFALL 20 INCHES IN
NORTHPORT, UPWARD OF CLOSE TO 30
INCHES OF RAIN FROM THIS SYSTEM
WHEN ALL SAID AND DONE AND THIS
AREA OF LOW PRESSURE ACROSS
ORLANDO, BRINGING HEAVY
RAINFALL, SO CATEGORY ONE STORM.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO WEAKEN AS IT
MOVES OUT INTO THE ATLANTIC,
THERE IS A CHANCE IT COULD
STRENGTHEN A LITTLE BIT, MAYBE
EVEN BACK TO A HURRICANE, WE ARE
ANTICIPATING A TROPICAL STORM
NEXT COUPLE HOURS.
MOST POWERFUL STORM IS OVER,
WE'LL STILL SEE IMPACT, HEAVY
RAINFALL, STORM SURGE, COUNTER
CLOCK WISE WIND IS PUSHING THE
ATLANTIC SIDE STORM SURGE TO
NORTH FLORIDA AND INTO GEORGIA
AND SOUTH CAROLINA, WHERE WE'RE
ANTICIPATING ANOTHER LANDFALL IN
THE NEXT 12 TO 24 HOURS.
YOU CAN SEE THE HEAVY RAINFALL
NOTHING ORLANDO TOWARD DAYTONA
BEACH, FLASH FLOOD WARNING,
WHERE FLOODING IS IMMINENT,
WE'LL GET TWO TO THREE INCHES
PER HOUR.
OVER TWO MILLION PEOPLE ARE
WITHOUT POWER.
THIS IS TODAY'S SITUATION AND WE
COULD BE WITHOUT POWER FOR WEEKS
IN SOME AREAS, EMERGENCY CREWS
CAN'T GET INTO.
THAT IS A BIG CONCERN AND STORY
WE'LL FOLLOW OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE DAYS AND WEEKS.
STILL HURRICANE WARNING FOR
CENTRAL FLORIDA AND TROPICAL
STORM WARNING FOR COAST OF NORTH
FLORIDA TO GEORGIA AND THE
CAROLINAS.
WE'RE NOT DONE WITH THIS STORM
YET, DEALING WITH A CATEGORY ONE
STORM AND EXPECTING IT TO WEAKEN
AS WE GO THROUGH THE NEXT COUPLE
OF DAYS AND MAKING ANOTHER
LANDFALL ON FRIDAY, WE THINK IN
COASTAL SOUTH CAROLINA.
HERE ARE IMPACTS, WE'RE DEALING
WITH HURRICANE-FORCE GUSTS AS IT
MOVES THROUGH THE REST OF
FLORIDA AND INTO GEORGIA AND
SOUTH CAROLINA.
WE'RE DEALING WITH HEAVY RAIN,
HURRICANE-FORCE WINDS AND POWER
OUTAGES, HEAVILY POPULATED
NEIGHBORHOODS FRIDAY AND
SATURDAY.
FLASH FLOODING IN GEORGIA AND
CAROLINAS HEADING INTO THE
WEEKEND AND GETTING INTO
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY, WILL THIS
IMPACT YOU IN THE MID-ATLANTIC
AND NORTHEAST?
YES, THE APPALACHIANS WILL GET A
HEAVY TRACK.
IMPACTING NORTH FLORIDA TO
GEORGIA, CAROLINAS AND THIS
MOUNTAINOUS TERRAIN IN PORTIONS
OF THE VIRGINIA AND WEST
VIRGINIA, TENNESSEE AND
KENTUCKY, FLOOD ALERTS FOR THE
MORNING, AFTERNOON AND WEEKEND
FOR MUCH OF THE STATE OF FLORIDA
AND INTO COASTAL GEORGIA AND
SOUTH CAROLINA.
RAIN STILL TO COME ANYWHERE FROM
EIGHT TO 12, EVEN 12 TO 18
INCHES, SO WE'LL SEE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
FLORIDA AFTER IAN IS GONE AND AS
WE GET INTO THE NEXT FIVE DAYS,
SEEING POTENTIAL FOR SIX TO
EIGHT, 12 INCHES OF RAINFALL FOR
PARTS OF THE MID-ATLANTIC AND
NORTHEAST.
FLASH FLOOD THREAT THROUGH TODAY
AND FRIDAY FOCUSING ON NORTHERN
PART OF FLORIDA, NORTH CENTRAL
FLORIDA AND THAT TRACK MOVES
INTO GEORGIA AND SOUTH CAROLINA,
WATCHES AND WARNINGS GOING
THROUGH THE NEXT 12 TO 24 HOURS
FOR NORTH FLORIDA, GEORGIA,
SOUTH CAROLINA AND THEN WE'LL
HAVE TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS AS IT
GOES TOWARD THE MID-ATLANTIC,
HURRICANE WATCHES IN EFFECT
BECAUSE THAT SYSTEM IS GOING TO
HOLD TOGETHER AS IT MOVES INTO
THE ATLANTIC AND BRINGS
HURRICANE-FORCE GUSTS INTO
PORTIONS OF NORTHERN FLORIDA AND
TOWARD COASTAL GEORGIA AND SOUTH
CAROLINA AND REMEMBER, WE'RE
GOING TO SEE THAT STORM SURGE
BECAUSE COUNTER CLOCK WISE WINDS
WILL PUSH THE ATLANTIC SIDE
WATER IN TOWARD THE COASTLINE,
THAT WILL BE REALLY DANGEROUS,
AS WELL.
PEAK STORM SURGE WILL CAUSE
DAMAGE IN THE NEXT 12 TO 24
HOURS, SO WE CAN'T FORGET OUR
FRIENDS IN GEORGIA, SOUTH
CAROLINA AND NORTH CAROLINA, AS
WELL.
THE WORST OF THE STORM IS OVER,
BUT WE ARE STILL DEALING WITH
IMPACTS FROM NORTH FLORIDA,
PORTIONS OF ORLANDO IN TOWARD
DAYTONA AND THE CAROLINAS, WE
HAVE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
REGION, AS WELL.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE WORST
FOOTAGE YET, IT IS HARD FOR
EMERGENCY CREWS TO GET IN THERE
AND I'M REALLY CONCERNED ONCE
THE DAYLIGHT HITS WE'LL SEE SOME
OF THE WORST DAMAGE WE'VE EVER
SEEN IN